we lived by the Kanye and we died by the
Kanye a plot to target Robert Muller
spirals out of control and polarization
continues over the Pittsburgh
anti-semitic shooting I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
you know it took a big man to forgo
saying I told you so
when he tells somebody that something
was going to happen then it happened I
am NOT that man I'm going to tell you
exactly when I was right I was right
about Kanye West because of course I
mean come on
I wasn't the only one saying this will
get to Kanye West will also get to the
funniest story of the day and we'll get
to a lot of other material including a
weird segment on dr. feel that was those
really strange we'll get to all of that
in just one second first let's talk
about how you protect your eyes you're
using your screen more often than ever
right you're constantly on your phone
you are constantly on your laptop you
probably don't realize that the average
American is blasting their eyes bright
screens for at 11 hours a day and then
when I think about myself I'm thinking
like only 11 hours I'm awake for at
least 16 so that means that 14 of the 16
hours I'm probably on a screen well
that's why you should be protecting your
eyes with a pair of Felix gray glasses
that are available with or without a
prescription
Felix Craig glasses they're fantastic I
wear them when I'm not on the air they
filter out 90% of high-energy blue light
they eliminate the glare coming off of
all of those screens so you don't have
to worry about dry eyes or blurred
vision or headaches it seems like a
hassle to protect your eyes and you
would have to wear those really ugly
kind of goggle glasses but that's where
Felix Craig comes in because Felix grey
glasses aren't like the weird computer
glasses you've seen before there's no
yellow linen lens tint and they are
handcrafted from premium Italian acetate
they're not gonna make you look nerdy
which for me is a real accomplishment go
check it out right now
at Felix gray glasses comm slash Ben
don't spend another day looking at
screens and messing up your eyes without
the Felix gray glasses Felix gray
glasses dot-com slash men's protect
those eyes that's Felix gray glasses
dot-com / man very classy very classy
looking so go check them out right now
Felix gray glasses calm / man ok so I do
want to get to Kanye and I do want to
get to the Jacob wall story you've never
heard of Jacob wall well you will by the
end of today's show I want to get to all
of that but I have to begin today with
the full insanity on display from some
members of the hardcore left you know
there's a lot of talk this week about
radicalization and polarization and the
idea is that right-wing radicalization
is being led by the right-wing rhetoric
at Fox News and and the right-wing
from President Trump expressing at this
view point today is Paul Krugman who is
legitimately one of the worst columnist
in America he has heavy competition over
on the New York Times editorial page
with folks like Charles blow but Krugman
is truly in execrable columnist I
usually reserved that word only for
Michael moles but it certainly applies
to Paul Krugman as well Krugman has a
column today called the hate is on the
ballot next week and here is what he
says he says in America 2018 what about
ISM is the last refuge of scoundrels and
both sides ISM is the last refuge of
cowards so his suggestion here for folks
who don't know what these words mean
what about ISM is a kind of newfangled
word for you don't want to pay attention
to the stuff your own side is doing so
you blame the other side so if you're
talking about president Trump's sexual
infidelity then you say oh yeah well
what about Bill Clinton's sexual
infidelity
that would be what about ISM so he's
saying that what about ISM is now taking
place on the basis of rhetoric he says
if you hadn't noticed we're in the midst
of a wave of hate crimes just in the
past few days bombs were mailed to a
number of prominent Democrats plus CNN
then a gunman massacred 11 people at a
Pittsburgh synagogue meanwhile another
gunman killed two African Americans at a
Louisville supermarket after first
trying to unsuccessfully break into a
black church if he had gotten there now
earlier we probably would have had
another mass murder all of these hate
crimes seemed clearly links the climate
of paranoia and racism deliberately
fostered by President Trump and his
allies in Congress in the media killing
black people is an old American
tradition but is it experiencing a
revival in the Trump era that sentence
is purely despicable the idea that
killing black people is an old American
tradition but it is experiencing a
revival I assume what he means by that
is that slavery and Jim Crow were old
American traditions and that Trump is
reviving those which of course is a
complete lie he continued says when the
bombs were discovered many on the right
immediately claimed they were fake news
or a false flag operation by liberals
but the FBI quickly tracked down the
apparent source of the explosive devices
a fanatical Trump supporter who many are
already calling the maggi bomber well
that would be all of the folks on the
Left who wish to attribute his actions
directly to President from the man
arrested at the Tree of Life synagogue
Paul Krugman writes has been critical of
Trump who he apparently believes isn't
dan systematic enough but his rage seems
to have been fueled by conspiracy
theories being systematically spread by
Trump supporters the claim that Jewish
financiers are bringing brown people
into America
to displace white so here's when he gets
to the point he says he'll our Trump
apologists dealing with this ugly
picture partly through denial pretending
not to see any link between hateful
rhetoric and hate crimes but also
through attempts to spread the blame by
claiming the Democrats are just as bad
if not worse Trump supporters try to
kill his critics while some Trump
opponents have yelled at politicians and
restaurants now I know you're sitting
there you're yelling at your phone
you're yelling at your car radio you're
saying but Paul Krugman it's not just
that democrats have engaged in screaming
at people at restaurants the Volusia
County headquarters of the Republican
Party was shot up right people shot
bullets through the windows a day ago a
Bernie Sanders supporter shot up a bunch
of Congress people including Steve
Scalise whom he nearly murdered so what
are you talking about but that would be
what about ISM according to Paul Krugman
if you mentioned that that is now what
about ISM he says this what about isn't
doesn't stop with ik waiting protests
with violence it also relies on outright
lying and then he talks about Nancy
Pelosi
he says false equivalence portraying the
parties as symmetric even when they
clearly aren't has long been the norm
among self-proclaimed centrist and some
influential media figures it's a stance
that is hugely benefited the GOP as it
has increasingly become the party of
right-wing extremists you might have
thought that the horrifying events of
recent days would finally break the norm
but you would have been wrong both sides
ISM it turns out is a fanatical cult
impervious to evidence Trump famously
boasted that his supporters would stick
with him even if he shot someone on
Fifth Avenue what he didn't point out
was that pundits would piously attribute
the shooting to incivility and that
Sunday talk shows would feature Fifth
Avenue shooting advocates and give them
a respectful hearing this needs to stop
and those who keep practicing both sides
and need to be shamed at this point
pretending that both sides are equally
to blame or attributing political
violence to spreading hatred without
identifying who's responsible for that
spread is a form of deep cowardice the
fact is that one side of the political
spectrum says Paul Krugman is peddling
hatred while the other isn't and
refusing to point that out for fear of
sounding partisan is in effect lending
aid and comfort to the people poisoning
our politics yes heat is on the ballot
next week so it's the Democrats are
completely innocent the Republicans are
completely blameworthy for every
terrible thing that's been said leading
to a rash of hate crimes and it's not
just Paul Krugman saying this it's also
Don Lemon so Don Lemon on CNN a man who
we were
Paul defended an Tifa in recent weeks he
went on his show with Chris Cuomo the
more segments on CNN are always done
lemon with Chris Cuomo there they're
always just the worse it because again
it looks like it's just two blocks of
what clunking each other but here is Don
Lemon talking about he doesn't see
Democrats killing people over politics I
mean that's just not something that's a
well actually let's do this one first
Don Lemon says the biggest terror threat
is white men listen to how he listen to
his language sure he says we have to
stop demonizing people we have to stop
demonizing people but white men are the
devil here is Don Lemon saying the
biggest terror threat is white men so we
have to stop demonizing people and
realize the biggest terror threat in
this country is white men most of them
radicalized right up to the right and we
have to start doing something about them
there is no travel ban on them there is
no ban on you know they had the Muslim
ban there is no white guy ban so what do
we do about that so I've heard that
inflammatory rhetoric only is presence
on the right and I also don't know
whether Don Lemon can even hear the
words coming out of his own mouth he
says we need to stop demonizing people
also white men need to be stopped okay
well that's weird and listen
statistically speaking the majority of
terror killings in the United States
over the past years since 9/11 have been
perpetrated by white men that is true
that isn't and that is an accurate
statement it is also accurate to say
just statistically speaking that the
disproportionate number of murders
committed in the United States are
committed by young black men that
doesn't mean that we ought to be
targeting young black men or that we
ought to be targeting white men it means
that we ought to be targeting criminals
but Don Lemon is fully fine with
demonizing an entire segment of the
population on the basis of a few Fringe
actors who commit acts of evil and then
John lemon goes even further he says I
don't see Democrats killing people over
politics like that's not a thing that's
happening which is a weird thing to say
a year after somebody shot up a
congressional baseball game nearly
killed the House Majority Whip but here
is Don Lemon being an ignoramus
right-wing group killed the woman in
Charlottesville this guy is a right
winger who killed the people in the
synagogue
the the right-wingers sent bombs to CNN
and to Democrats I don't see Democrats
killing people because of political yeah
there may be put Democratic operatives
who are out of a ok and then when they I
said they tried to then both masks boot
and Don Lemon went nuts how dare you say
that the rhetoric of the Democrats is
not the same as the rhetoric of the
Republicans hey this is the routine that
Democrats are pulling these days brian
Stelter
he's the sunday news host on CNN he says
I hope that Fox personalities think
about their role in jacking up the
climate of violence iczer hope some of
those foxholes some of those
commentators take a moment take a minute
to think about their role in this
environment hopefully there's some
soul-searching right now in the wake of
this massacre I do use a fever right now
I mean what are you thinking what are
you thinking they like ratings they like
winning the ratings war that's what this
is about
and then there's Allison Cammarata
suggesting that Fox News host don't care
if people die so long as they get their
ratings Steve Schmidt former McCain
campaign advisor in 2008 who's been
making Bank off of being the Republican
who's not actually a Republican on MSNBC
for years he blames Mark Levin and Rush
Limbaugh he says they have blood on
their hands the propaganda industry that
she commands with the vial president
that she serves abetted by Mark Levin
and Rush Limbaugh and Breitbart
and News Buster's and judicial watch and
all the rest of them have blood on their
hands for the incitements that they have
made that have triggered and radicalized
these crazy people it is deliberate so
we've talked about radicalization
alright we've talked about
radicalization and the left keep saying
it's radicalization of rhetoric on the
part of people on the right that it's
led to this increase in hate crimes
against achill II unverified as of yet
because we don't have the FBI's
statistics for this year they're only
done a little bit later but beyond that
this idea is that it's only the rhetoric
of the right that is to blame and if you
mention the rhetoric of the left and
this is what about ISM it is what about
ISM there are two ways to radicalize
folks and they're interrelated one is
inflammatory rhetoric rhetoric is
connected with violence you
is connected with action now that
doesn't mean that rhetoric is always
incitement to violence that's an actual
legal standard then nothing President
Trump has said means but there's no
question that rhetoric and violence or
rhetoric and radicalism these things are
related but there are two ways in which
rhetoric can lead to radicalization one
is radical rhetoric leading to
radicalization the other is gas lighting
and I'm gonna explain what I mean by
this in just one second because I know
that there are people who are listening
to this show right now who are watching
this show right now and they are feeling
more angry and more radical after having
listened to Paul Krugman after having
listened to Steve Schmidt after having
listened to Don Lemon I'll explain why
that is and why the left is doing a deep
disservice and contributing contributing
to a highly ratcheted up polarized
political environments including
inflammatory rhetoric in just one second
first let's talk about what you do for
your stamps oh look you love the post
office it offers a lot of great services
but you don't actually want to go down
to the post office and stand in line
instead you want to be able to sit at
your desk and get all the great services
of the post office just like you're able
to get products in any other way well
this is why you need to go over to
stamps calm with stamps calm you can
access all the amazing services of the
post office directly from your desk 24/7
when it is convenient for you buy and
print official US postage for any letter
any package using your own computer and
printer the mail carrier picks it up
just click print mil you're done it
could not be easier we use stamps calm
here at the Daily wire offices I use
stamps calm in my own home because it
saves me time and it saves me money
right now use promo code Shapiro and get
a special offer 55 bucks of free postage
digital scale and a 4 week trial which
is pretty solid again that digital scale
allows you to get exact postage every
time and the deal includes up to 55
bucks of free postage that digital scale
and the four week trial go to stamps
calm before you do anything else click
on the radio microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in promo code
Shapiro that stamps comm promo code
Shapiro for that special deal again
stamps.com promo code Shapiro so Steve
Schmidt is a schmuck okay when he says
that mark Levin and Rush Limbaugh are to
blame for an anti-semite shooting up a
synagogue mark levin happens to be
Jewish by the way and then Chris Hayes
in that same clip comes back and says oh
yeah and they're all there used to be
all these Republicans used to condemn
bad rhetoric like Mitt Romney and ben
shapiro like these people haven't
listened for five minutes to my show in
which i condemn bad rhetoric on all
sides on routine
like legitimately everyday everyday but
and there's a narrative that's being
driven here by Don Lemon a guy who
defended an Tifa right that only one
side of the aisle is responsible and if
you mentioned the other side of the
aisle this is because you are being
dishonest
this is gaslighting so a lot of
President Trump's critics have in some
cases rightly suggested that President
Trump gaslights his opponents what he
does is he says something that is false
people say that his policies odd I have
never said that that's not what I said
what I said is something completely
different
who you gonna believe you are your own
lying eyes Hey the left is doing that
right now what the left is doing is
engaging in inflammatory rhetoric
they're claiming that Republicans across
the country are responsible for an
anti-semitic slaying at a synagogue I
responsible for a nutjob a whack job in
Florida sending pipe bombs to Democratic
officials and then they say who us were
radicalizing people no how dare you how
dare you we're just here calling it like
we see it were just here being honest
about the situation that we face and at
the same time saying well no Democrats
have never engaged in violence it's not
just the Congressional baseball shooting
folks okay within the past few years
we've seen riots in Ferguson Missouri we
saw riots in Baltimore Maryland we saw
riots in Charlotte North Carolina
all of those riots were pushed for were
inspired were were justified by a number
of Democratic officials basically saying
that the cause that was being rioted
about was a just cause
when police has five police officers
were shot to death in Dallas a couple of
years ago a few years ago President
Obama had said a lot of things against
the police just before that Obama wasn't
responsible for the shooting but if
we're gonna talk about a radical
political environment that oftimes is
involved with raising the temperature so
that violence breaks out to ignore all
of this is just ignorant and not only
ignorance it's a deliberate attempt to
drive you nuts it's a deliberate attempt
to raise the temperature and that is
unsustainable it's unsustainable and
when Metron Representative Maxine Waters
is saying that President Trump should
take responsibility for the bomb threats
the same Maxine Waters who called the LA
riots an uprising and called for
Republican public officials to be
confronted in public places when Julia
Jaffe of Jiki was blaming President
Trump for his extreme rhetoric and then
goes on CNN and
the Trump radicalizes more people than
Isis when Vice President Joe Biden says
that Americans should vote for
politicians out of character the same
Joe Biden who said that Mitt Romney was
going to reinstate Fox in the United
States of course we feel like we're
being gas-lit I have some more thoughts
on this in just a second of course we
feel like we're being gas-lit because we
are being Gasland okay the Democrats
have suggested that they are responsible
for none of what has happened president
Trump is the beginning of time with
President Trump the universe burst into
being suddenly the Big Bang of politics
occurred and suddenly time began flowing
forward before there was no such thing
as time then President Trump sprung on
the scene and suddenly he was the
creator Lord and master of all bad
rhetoric in the United States
I will condemn President Trump when I
believe that he has used inflammatory
rhetoric I will condemn other hosts when
I think that they are using inflammatory
rhetoric or exaggerating their case or
making things up I do it every single
day on the program but I'm not gonna sit
by and pretend that the left is not
responsible for at least an equal amount
of this sort of rhetoric I'm not going
to pretend that anti-semitism among
white supremacist is somehow a massively
greater threat to Jews across the world
and in the United States than the
Democratic Party's full embrace of
radical anti-semites like Linda Sarsour
that's the mainstream Democratic Party
doing that
hey this is it's it's a mark of both
political immaturity and deep and deep
philosophical shallowness to refuse to
look in the mirror and Democrats right
now are refusing to look in the mirror
there are Republicans who for years have
been refusing to look in the mirror I've
been a big advocate of everybody ought
to look in the mirror and it's all of
our responsibilities to take the
temperature down that's something we
actually ought to be doing
but Democrats aren't interested in doing
that they're interested in raising the
temperature does Paul Krugman think the
temperature is raised or lowered when he
suggests that Republicans are all a
bunch of evil people who don't care
whether folks get shot at a synagogue
does Don Lemon think he's making the
country more or less polarized more or
less radicalized when he suggests that
President Trump and Republicans are
responsible for terror attacks do they
think that they're making things better
of course they don't think they're
making things better
if folks on CNN can accuse Fox News
hosts of dialing for ratings then CNN is
doing exactly the same thing with its
own basin I'm amused amused by Democrats
and and CNN hosts who suggest while
Republicans are engaged in
conspiratorial thinking we never engage
in conspiratorial thinking really I've
been alive for the past twenty years
I'm old enough to remember when you
suggested that Halliburton was behind
the Iraq war when you suggested the
George W Bush lied specifically to get
American soldiers killed because Iraq
was a war for oil I'm old enough to
remember when you suggested without any
evidence whatsoever that Donald Trump
actively coordinated with the Russian
government to skew the results of this
election I've been here the whole time
and you have too bad rhetoric has been a
part of American politics for a very
long time it has ratcheted up in recent
years it did not start with President
Trump president Trump exacerbates it
because President Trump has never
lowered the temperature on anything in
his life but that does not mean that he
is the only one who's engaged in this
the media have ramped this thing up to
11 I've been saying this for years
President Trump is at 11 the media are
at 11 and then they're surprised when
the temperature is is overheated you gas
late people they get angry they get
radicalized and you want I've never seen
Republicans conservatives as angry as I
saw them about a month ago during the
Brett Kavanaugh saga that wasn't a
result of deplorable republicanism that
was a result of the Democrats engaging
in extreme partisanship and extreme
rhetoric failing to recognize what
exactly is happening here the calling it
what about ISM when you suggest
correctly that bad things are happening
on all sides and that everybody is kind
of acting like garbage right now that is
contributing to this environment that is
making things significantly worse and I
think folks on the Left know this but I
think there are some folks on the left
you don't care because they are so
ensconced in their partisan worldview
that to even acknowledge that folks on
the Run zone side are engaged in bad
behavior would be to lend credence to
the other side and when it comes to
defeating Trump everything is on the
table up to and including lying about
the other side and more importantly
lying about your own side in the mark of
a good person and the mark of a good
political movement is the capacity to
look at yourself recognize where you're
flawed and try to become better all the
people in your life that you know and
that you like when you
make a critique of them their first
reaction and your first reaction to
their first reaction is okay maybe I
should think about that maybe I should
think about that right when I when I'm
criticized my first reaction generally
is maybe I didn't do something wrong and
sometimes I did do something wrong and I
have to change but nobody seems to want
to do any sort of self-reflection
because we're in the middle of bashing
each other across the skull with bricks
as hard as we can and then suggesting
that we are innocent in this brick fight
that's not the way that any of this
works and well in just a second I want
to talk about the latest from Pittsburgh
president from visited Pittsburgh what
was the fallout from that plus we're
gonna talk about white privilege we're
going to talk about the kanye west story
that there's a lot of stuff coming up
but first let's talk about what you're
gonna do in case of there's an emergency
so there's some sort of natural disaster
emergency strike without warning we're
surprised when the power goes out were
surprised when the when it turns out
that the grocery store shelves are empty
where he can't get to the grocery store
that's why you ought to be prepared
right now so you plan now so you don't
have to worry about it later
and that's where my Patriot supply comes
in if you don't have an emergency food
supply
you ought to and that's why you got to
trust my folks and my Patriot supply a
two-week food kick gets you started this
week its own special for just 75 bucks
when you go to my special website
prepare with been calm or call eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen that's prepare with been calm
or call eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen the food kits include
meals that last up to 25 years in
storage order now be prepared there are
no surprises again eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen or
prepare with been calm that's prepared
with Ben's icon eight eight eight eight
oh three fourteen thirteen get prepared
so you never have to worry about this
again folks in the office have tried the
food they say that it tastes like home
cookin and again it lasts up to 25 years
in storage prepare with been calm eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen for that special deal seventy
five bucks for a 2-week food kid go
check it out right now okay so as all of
this breaks out we could be having a
moment of unity we could instead we
won't we could be having a moment when
we all say something terrible just
happened what can we do to fight
anti-semitism instead what we're going
to do is use every individual evil
incident as an excuse to bash each other
and Club each other so President Trump
goes any visits Pittsburgh and
protesters of course show up to protest
President Trump
now this is not a bunch of people who
happen to be you know Philo somatic
wonderful Pro Jewish people who are just
angry at President Trump for his failure
to sufficiently condemn the alt-right in
2015 it turns out that all of these
protesters are radically left generally
anti-israel protesters who are out there
protesting president Trump shocker but
the media is gonna cover this as though
this is a referendum on President
Trump's rhetoric when in fact it's just
a bunch of people who don't like Trump
and they're using this as an opportunity
to Club Trump they've been doing this
for a while now media the media
malfeasance on the pits even on
Pittsburgh has been truly astonishing in
the the the story that I talked about a
couple of days ago in which the media
suggested that a Jewish that Jewish
leaders didn't want Trump to come to
Pittsburgh and then they quoted a group
called bend the arc and refused to
acknowledge that that was a group run by
Alexander Soros George Soros his son
that stated mission is to stop Trump
that's media malfeasance
the media I mean another example of
media malfeasance on Pittsburgh issue so
the chief rabbi of Israel is rabbi david
lau so rabbi loud there's a lot of
controversy in israel over whether the
conservative in the reform movements in
israel ought to be accepted by the
rabbinate my personal opinion is no
because they're not halakhah right then
they don't they don't work according to
jewish law there's a good arguments we
made whether or not there actually ought
to be a Rabbinate in israel whether
there ought to be like an official
religious rabbit in israel but put that
aside that controversy has existed in
the aftermath of the shooting there was
a story that went out at the washington
post and a bunch of other leftist
outlets trying to suggest that david lau
refused to acknowledge that the shooting
happened at a synagogue they suggested
that rabbi Lau had said that the
shooting did not happen at a synagogue
it happened at a place of significant
Jewish character that was a lie if you
go back and you read David Lau's
comments in Hebrew he calls it
specifically a Beit Knesset which is to
say a place where people pray right
which is a synagogue and the media
completely misreported it because they
have an agenda which is to even split
the Jewish community between the
Orthodox and the non-orthodox in the
middle of an anti-semitic shooting in
any case these protesters gathered for
Trump and watch the media coverage is
pretty astonishing that sadness that
that absolute shock at what has happened
has turned into anger with news of the
president's
there are several hundred people here at
this protest getting ready to march just
as the president is expected to land in
in Pittsburgh and and move around the
city there is a second protest in the
neighborhood president Donald Trump in
this neighborhood tonight is definitely
unwelcome
okay he's unwelcome in this neighborhood
and then you look at the video and there
are people wearing sciu jackets and
carrying ACLU handmade and not not
handmade printed out placards okay the
the idea that all of these people are
just grassroots folks who are showing up
with no agenda other than they're just
very upset about President Trump and his
and his feelings about anti-semitism
it's just nonsense but that's not the
way the media cover all of this and then
the media of course decided they were
going to cover in great specificity a
family of one of the synagogue's
shooting victims rejecting a Trump
meeting saying that he was blaming the
community they neglect of course to
mention that one of the people who was
shot and survived was in fact a trump
voter and that there were other Trump
people who have fans of Trump but
Trump's a polarizing guy this is not any
great shock I mean we've all known this
for a while but the media have decided
to play this up and the Democrats have
decided to play this up too for
political purposes so President Trump
wanted to do a unity rally in Pittsburgh
he wanted the mayor to come he wanted
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer to come
they all turned him down they all turned
him down why would they turn him down
well specifically for political purposes
let's be real about this this is not
over
outrage and associations with
anti-semites if it were they wouldn't be
running keith ellison for the head of
the DNC this is specifically about they
don't like Trump and this is a club they
can wield against Trump that's really
cynical dividing Americans even further
on the basis of this stuff is cynical
now with that said does President Trump
have an unfortunate tendency of putting
his foot so far down his mouth that it
goes through his colon out his ass and
then back into his mouth again creating
an Ouroboros of stupidity you bet he
does so President Trump tweeted this out
after visiting Pittsburgh I mean it's
just ridiculous he tweeted out Melania
and I were treated very nicely yesterday
in Pittsburgh the office of the
president was shown great respect and a
very sad and solemn day weird treaty so
harmony he means treated smart protest
was not seen by us staged far away the
fake news stories were just the opposite
disgraceful okay so it is true as I say
Media have Miss covered this story from
beginning to end it is also true that
when you go and visit the site of a mass
anti-semitic shooting the worst in
American history the key central part of
the story is not how you were treated
that's not really the important part of
the story it's not and it looks like
grandstanding mr. president please don't
do that I always say please don't say
just he's not going to listen but and
this of course is not is not helping in
any serious way okay
well meanwhile there are a couple of
other stories that that we must comment
on here so as I said long ago live by
the Kanye die by the Kanye so Kanye West
became beloved of the right for the last
six seven months after he started making
noises about how he loves President
Trump and he was wearing a Maggie hat
and he was saying that he was thinking
freely all of which is totally fine but
as I tweeted as soon as he started doing
this live by the Kanye die by the Kanye
Kanye West is not a stable figure he is
not somebody who decided to become a an
ideological conservative after reading
the combined works of William F Buckley
and Russell Kirk Kanye West is a guy who
sort of says whatever is on his mind
that day well that resulted in a
reversal on Twitter yesterday he is not
rejected President Trump or ripped into
President Trump but he started tweeting
out about sort of his political leanings
now he said I support creating jobs and
opportunities for people who need them
the most
I support prison reform I support
common-sense gun laws that will make our
world safer and then he continued he
said I support those who risk their
lives to serve and protect us and I
support holding people who misused their
power accountable I believe in love and
compassion for people seeking asylum and
parents are fighting to protect their
children from violence and war all that
sounds like a stump speech and then he
gets to the point he finally finally
tweets out I introduced Candace Owens
this be Candace Owens the the black
conservative who was associated with
with Kanye's move to the right I
introduced Candace to the person who
made the logo and they didn't want their
name on it so she used mine I never
wanted any association with blood said I
have nothing to do with it
so blex it is a movement that kind that
Candace has been pushing and Charlie
Kirk has been pushing to get black folks
to leave the Democratic Party and in
announcing blech set Candace suggested
that the logo for blood suit was
designed by Kanye West he obviously does
not feel that way
and he's upset about it and he tweeted
out my eyes are now wide open and now
realized I've been used to spread
messages I don't believe in I am
distancing myself from politics and
completely focusing on being creative so
ouch and also ouch
so that's not good but when you bet on
people who are not the most stable
people in the world and you pretend that
they are deeply stable this is a not
unpredictable consequence I think it is
fair to say that is not the least
predictable consequence that has ever
happened in human history fortunately
that was not the the dumbest story of
the day the dumbest story of the day
came courtesy of a guy named Jacob wool
I'm gonna explain this story to you in
just a second because it is too wild and
ridiculous for me to forego on this of
all days we'll discuss that in just a
second now this is the kind of story
where to really enjoy it properly you're
going to want to drink in your hand
you're gonna want a glass of wine a beer
a spirit some liquor you're gonna want
some of that in your hand well the way
you can get that in your hand without
actually having to get up off of your
couch while you're listening right now
is saucy it's the alcohol delivery app
saucy delivers your favorite wine beer
and liquor right to your door on demand
now if you're in LA the Bay Area Chicago
San Diego Sacramento your saucy order
will arrive at your door in under 30
minutes ready to drink for everybody
else saucy can deliver beer wine and
liquor to your door in two days or less
nationwide there are no order minimums
no delivery fees no running to the store
if you've got the saucy app you got a
fully stocked bar directly on your phone
in the middle of a party and you don't
have time to get up and leave and go
over to the liquor store you're just
going that saucy app and there it is
right at your door for a limited time
you can get 15 bucks off when you
download the saucy app and enter promo
code Ben that's the saucy app spelled
sau cey enter promo code Ben for $15 off
again get that saucy app today and use
promo code Ben it really is great for
parties I've had parties where we've run
out of liquor
not because of May I'm not a heavy
drinker but others have been drinking
and I need more alcohol and then we grab
the saucy app and that liquid shows up
right at our door just the way we
ordered it sauc ey enter promo code Ben
for $15 off go check it out right now
okay I want to get into this Jacob Boyle
story also dr. Phil we're gonna get into
that in just a second but for all of
those myriad glories you're going to
have to go over to daily wire.com and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily wire comic
sup that comes along with all sorts of
great benefits the rest of my shall live
the rest of Andrew Clavin shall live the
rest of Michael moles is terrible show
life you also get access to the Sunday
special we have an amazing Sunday
special coming up this week
tucker carlson is stopping by here's
what it sounds like hey it's tucker
carlson I'm in Los Angeles and somehow
wound up in Ben Shapiro studio we had
this kind of unbelievable conversation
for an hour which I mean bad places i
did not expect to go and i just loved it
and i hope you liked it it's on his
sunday special tucker is a kick and
you're really going to enjoy that sunday
special it's really it's fun and i think
deep and interesting and quirky it's it
is one of the better sunday specials
we've ever done for sure so you're gonna
want to go check that out when you get
the $99 package which is our annual
subscription then you get all of those
things you get to be part of our mailbag
gets you all those things and you get
the leftist tears hot or cold tumbler
look at it
feast your eyes upon it it's an
invisibility mode because we are abroad
once you go to Canada things should
start disappearing it's very weird but
you can go check that out also when you
get all of those things you also get
access to the daily wire backstage
coming up election night Tuesday
November 6 don't miss our election night
daily wire backstage god-king jeremy
boring me Andrew Klavan Michael moles
for some odd reason alicia Kraus and
Colton Haas actually is gonna be
stopping by we'll be covering all the
latest election news as it happens so be
sure to tune in as always only daily
wire subscribers get to ask the
questions because we will pry those
dollars from you at any cost so make
sure to subscribe today go over to daily
wire calm and do that we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so how crazy are politics
well Kanye West was the second craziest
story of the day the first craziest
story of the day yesterday was this
crazy story about folks who are trying
to sink Robert Muller they're very upset
with Robert Muller and they believe that
Robert Muller is somehow it deeply
compromised how's he compromised well
he's compromised because he's
investigating Trump and therefore there
was a scheme to find women and pay them
to lie about being sexually assaulted by
Robert Muller
I kid you not according to the daily
beats the scheme became public on
Tuesday when Robert Muller staff
formally asked the FBI to launch an
investigation into the matter but for
weeks it has been simmering below the
surface with numerous reporters having
been tipped off by a woman who claims
she'd been approached with promises of
cash at the center of the scheme is
publicity-hungry Republican lobbyist
Jack Burkman who has repeatedly dabbled
in Internet conspiracy theories in the
past including promoting the idea the
murdered DNC staffer Seth rich was
killed by deep state government
operatives Berkman denied involvement in
any attempts to pay people to frame or
accuse Muller but he also claims he has
witnesses who are going to expose the
special counsel as a sexual harasser he
scheduled a Thursday press conference at
a Holiday Inn in Northern Virginia to
introduce his first accuser number one
if you ever are attempting to launch
incredible fashion some sort of
accusation you should upgrade from the
holiday in just two recommendations like
here we are in the parking lot of Motel
6 the lights always left on for you
ain't good luck with this that's not the
part it's a Berkman says that we're
gonna prove that Robert Muller is a
drunk and a sexual abuser yeah sure we
are but that's not the part that's best
so the best part is that Berkman
apparently hired I he hired a Intel
agency an Intel agency that was that was
supposed to investigate
Robert Muller in his efforts to dig up
dirt on Muller Berkman appears from
enlisted outside help
Jacob wool is a right-wing Twitter
personality who's tweeted inane things
for years about Magne Magne President
Trump he's a self-described friend of
Berkman he said Berkman had told him
he'd hired Matthew Cohen who claims to
be a managing partner at the private
investigations company surefire
intelligence to assist with the
investigation only one problem
who
is Matthew Cohen who is Matthew Cohen
Matthew Cohen as it turns out is Jacob
wool okay and Jacob will apparently set
up a bunch of fake LinkedIn accounts for
people who worked for surefire
intelligence by grabbing all these just
random pictures from the internet and
using them as employee pictures for his
fake business so for example he said
that the investigator was named Donald
treehorn okay that is a stock photograph
of an actor I mean he just used that and
then that wasn't the and then the
tel-aviv station chief he called Italian
Yves only one problem that's a picture
of Bar Refaeli the the Israeli
supermodel so he he went through all
this trouble I feel bad for him a little
bit he went through all this trouble to
create a fake business to hide what he
was doing from the government and then
he went and got pictures of actors and
used them as his fake employees the
financial investigator at surefire
intelligence is supposedly a guy named
Simon Frick who's Simon Frick it's a
picture of Christoph Waltz it's a pretty
solid hire there it is then I got the
eye from inglorious bastards to be the
financial investigator at surefire
intelligence pretty and I mean Christoph
Waltz in' in inglourious basterds does
have a good record of tracking people
down but I mean my goodness
apparently the deputy director of
operations for surefire intelligence is
dr. Mike Harding over the First Baptist
Church of Troy Michigan so well done
this is the best part of this is that
wool was asked about all of this and he
denied all of it and then it turns out
that he registered the website under the
name under the phone number of his
mother this is what The Daily Beast is
saying so suffice it to say our politics
is too crazy people have been driven out
of their minds sure fires web site
domain tato list and email address
bearing wolves name and that of a
legally suspect financial firm he held
next management sure fires website also
contains images uploaded to the same
google cloud account
wall who hinted at the molar
investigations on Monday night tonight
any involvement in or knowledge of
sure-fire he said he works for an
influencer marketing company in LA yeah
turns out that um not so much so yes
things
crazy out there and everybody needs to
calm down now that did not end the crazy
yesterday there's a lot of crazy
yesterday my favorite bit of crazy
actually was not even that it came
courtesy of Joe Donnelly this is
late-breaking crazy last night so Joe
Donnelly is the Democratic Senate
candidate in Indiana is the current
senator in Indiana and he was in a
debate and he started trying to describe
his staff um it didn't go well here's
what Joe Donnelly had to say our state
director is Indian American but he does
an amazing job our director of all
constituent services she's African
American but she does an even more
incredible job than you could ever
imagine but hey I wasn't aware that it
finally had coltan back here exactly
what that means she's an Indian American
but she does an incredible job you know
like I'm like the other Indian Americans
my state director of grassroots
operations is black but she does an
incredible job now imagine that we're a
Republican with that headline ever stop
no the headline would never stop ever
ever ever ever but that's the way that
this works now is that Democrats can say
the most absurd on their face stupid
ridiculous things and get away with it
but you have to enjoy I mean that is a
full on Michael Scott fail right there
that is the office style Michael Scott
failure so well done well done Democrats
just amazing stuff okay so in just a
second I want to talk to you about a
segment on dr. Phil that really suggests
one of the big problems in the country
right now so I don't know i'ma try dr.
Phil I don't watch a lot of daytime TV I
know a lot of people love dr. Phil he
did a segment in which he had on Michael
Eric Dyson and a bunch of other sort of
social activists particularly in the
black community and he did what he
called a study what was this study well
he got a bunch of people of different
races and sexes and sexual orientations
to line up bunch of young people in line
and then he had somebody asked them some
thirty questions about privilege in
their life and then he had you take a
step forward for everything that you
have every privilege had and take a step
back for every privilege you didn't have
so it was stuff like if both your if one
of your parents works nights to support
the family take a step back if you've
ever been sexual
harass take a step back and by the end
of that little exercise some of the some
of the young people were you know pretty
far forward on the stage and some of the
young people were pretty far backward on
the stage and here's how some of those
young people responded to learning about
their privilege thank you all for
participating today I'm very aware of my
white privilege but it really shows
through when I looks behind me and most
of the people in the very back were
people of color
I was in the back I'm not ever in the
back of anything that I do being in the
front made me feel uncomfortable it's an
awkward feeling to like be up there and
know that like everyone behind you can
look at you right but you can't look at
them I landed in the very back of the
crowd I was a bit surprised I didn't
have very much growing up but I've
always thought that there are other
people who had less I didn't know I was
going to end up in the front the way I
was raised by the border in Mexico that
I would be less privileged though it's
weird to know that I am actually doing
good I think talking about white
privilege in a room full of white people
is awkward
but in a roomful of different ethnic
groups I think is necessary it's a very
sensitive topic you don't want to offend
anyone but it's true there are racial
and so how is any of this useful so
here's the question dr. Phil says ah
this is this was really interesting and
really it was it was real as something
I'm glad we did well
dr. field it's not it's actually a bad
thing the reason it's a bad thing is you
can listen to what some of these young
people are saying so there's a woman who
is standing in the back and she appears
to be of maybe Filipino extraction and
she says you know it never occurred to
me that I had it rough right it always
occurred to me that there are people who
are worse off than I was why is that a
bad attitude that's a really good
attitude and being awakened to the fact
that you have it really rough and being
thought thinking of yourself as a victim
is a really easy path to slide into
resentment and anger and rage and other
people who quote unquote have it better
you know there's a young black woman
there who says you know I've never stood
in the back in my life that's the right
attitude the right attitude is you don't
have to stand in the back just because
of dint of birth or problems that you
had growing up in America you can
but the entire privilege discussion is
supposed to not awaken people to the
fact that there is inequality in the
United States in terms of where we start
we all know that you have to be an idiot
not to know that but it's supposed to
instead instill in people who have who
were better off growing up that they
somehow had an unfair advantage over
others and to instill in people who are
worse off growing up that the people in
the front screwed them right to even set
it up in this sort of physical dichotomy
where the people who aren't quote
unquote more privileged are ahead and
the people who are less privileged are
behind is to suggest a sort of back of
the bus mentality oh you've been treated
by America wrongly somebody has
victimized you in some way well
virtually none like I none of the
questions that were asked in that
segment we're about members of the group
victimizing each other
it was never if you've been victimized
by somebody in this group take a step
back if you victimize somebody in this
group take a step forward none of those
questions were about that if it were
about that then we could talk about
whether inequality and inequity are
linked but it wasn't about that it was
about have you had a rougher or have you
had it better why do you need full
discussions of who's had it there's no
more boring discussion in the world then
who's had a rougher or who or who's had
it better and I don't just mean boring
in terms of like actually not
interesting I mean that it is useless
and counterproductive I mean there's a
famous joke that says there's nobody
more boring than a person who you ask
them how they are and they actually tell
you okay the same thing is true when it
comes to this sort of stuff because in a
country that is free where you started
is not where you end up and Riaan
collating the idea that where you
started is where you end up is a way of
ensuring that people don't do all that
they can in order to better themselves
thinking of yourself as a victim is the
first path toward irrelevant and toward
destroying your own life it's really
really dumb stuff it's really dumb stuff
well in just a second I want to talk
about specifically you know all of all
of the kind of attempts to paint
Americans as victims there's a study out
today here's an example there's a study
out today that is from USA Today and
what it says that 62% of jobs don't
support middle-class life after
accounting for the cost of living well
that sounds terrible doesn't it it
sounds like 62% of Americans are
basically on the verge of poverty well
that's not what the study says so here's
what the study says
despite an unemployment rate that has
reached a 50-year low of 3.7 percent
most jobs across the United States don't
support a middle class or better
lifestyle leaving many Americans
struggling according to a new study 62%
of jobs fall short of that middle class
standard when factoring in both wages
and the cost of living in the metro area
where the job is located according to a
study by Third Way a think-tank that
advocates center-left ideas shocker
now here's the problem okay it says a
slight majority of Americans 52 percent
do live in middle-class households
according to a recent annual report by
the Pew Research Center another 20
percent or so
live in upper income households in other
words 72 percent of Americans are middle
income or better our middle class or
better so how does that square with 62%
of middle-class jobs don't actually lead
to middle-class lifestyles it says
that's because they're juggling multiple
jobs or relying on investments and
inheritance or other household members
who may have higher paying jobs right so
what most households in the United
States have two people working most
households in the United States have a
person who may be working a couple of
jobs my entire life growing up both my
parents worked my dad was home more than
my mom and my dad worked multiple jobs
at a time when when he was young with my
mom like this is it's it's it's so
foolish to suggest that people are
starving in New York City while earning
$50,000 a year if you really believe
that you're starving living in New York
City may be the solution to that is to
get rid of rent control thereby lowering
the rents not to start saying that
capitalism is responsible for all of
these failures it's just the the
twisting of statistics is pretty
astonishing it says the rankings
highlight some vivid contrast a factory
machinist in Cedar Rapids Iowa earns an
average of 46 thousand dollars a year
more than enough to meet the $40,000
threshold for a middle class job in the
area a similar machinist makes more 57
grand in San Francisco but that's far
short of the 82 grand minimum from
middle-class job in that area according
to the report why do you think that is
that's because San Francisco is governed
like a liberal area with heavy rent
control so the problem here is not lack
of jobs or lack of opportunity the
problem is that there are a bunch of
regulations that make life more
expensive in leftist areas and maybe if
you're a machinist you're better off
living in Idaho or Iowa maybe you're
better off moving
Cedar Rapids then living in San
Francisco is that a possibility but we
can never contemplate that possibility
everybody is entitled to a job wherever
they want and also entitled to a rent
controlled apartment that raises rents
for everybody else so just genius stuff
now speaking of fun with statistics I do
want to point one thing out cuz I've
seen this a little bit maybe I'll say
this for things I hate so we'll do a
quick thing I like and then we'll do a
quick thing that I hate so things that I
like so this week because I did a some
Jewish music yesterday I decided that
the rest of the week I'm gonna pick some
of my favorite ninguna Manny Guney Mar
kind of Jewish tunes this one was
actually written and performed by a
friend of mine from back in high school
and and it's quite good
methought about this actually so his
name is a Tonka a tonk cats was in my
high school class and if you go back to
one of his very first albums you can
actually hear me playing violin in the
background on the album just needed
violinist for like a cutter too and so I
came in and played the violin in the
background a little bit here is Eitan
singing this is this
this phrase is lamonica a locum chi it's
it's all about obviously I want to find
the exact translation it says act for
your sake our God and not from ours
behold our spiritual position destitute
and empty-handed the soul is yours the
body is your handiwork take pity on your
labor this is something that you say on
Yom Kippur night in in Slee coat which
are sort of these special prayers that
we say during this period so this is so
here is a here's a time singing it
you know
[Music]
be the same die
aha
again
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
made us
the
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
so it's really nice stuff eight times
really talented guy I got the words
wrong very beginning in Hebrew it's
Lamonica Elkanah la ceiba la la new
right a humerus a medallion break came
how to shymala about goof Pollock who
saw I'm Allah so for those who speak
Hebrew I want to make sure I got you
every time I screw up the Hebrew believe
it or not there are people who actually
email me and they say you screwed it up
so a couple of days ago I got a bunch of
emails from Orthodox Jews saying I'd
screwed up so I tried to correct myself
when I do okay so that's the thing I
like for today
yeah spirituality it's kind of a nice
thing from time to time okay time for a
quick thing that I hate so there's a
statistic that's been cited routinely by
the mainstream media suggesting that
Jews are no longer safe in the United
States and they cite a study put out by
the anti-defamation league which
suggests that there has been a 57%
increase in anti-semitic incidents in
2017 that figure was reported in NPR to
the New York Times The Washington Post
and a bunch of other media outlets that
is not what the study shows that is not
true there's a full breakdown of this
over at tablet basically the study does
not claim to actually count anti-semitic
incidents but rather the reporting of
the incidents which is not the same
thing when the FBI reports what hate
crimes are it reports one that they've
investigated not just reports of hate
crimes so this this ADL study counts
incidents that have been reported to the
ADL by the media more enforcement and
the public and the ADL openly
acknowledges that some of the increase
in documented incidents is not an actual
increase but results from more people
reporting incidents to the ADL than ever
before also the report doesn't just
count certifiable anti-semitic incidents
but any incident that results in Jews
perceiving themselves as being
victimized due to their Jewish identity
so that methodological tick includes 163
bomb threats made to the JCC even though
the - even though that perpetrator was
not motivated by anti-semitism right
20:17 saw an elevated kind of response
from the Jewish community to perceived
threat but that doesn't necessarily mean
that the number of actual violent
incidents on record has increased in
fact the ADL study shows a forty seven
percent decrease in physical assaults
against Jews in the United States from
37 to 19 so it shows a 57% increase in
incidents overall but a forty seven
percent decrease in physical assaults in
17 which is not consistent with all of
the other data so this is you know let's
get the data right do I think that
there's increased anti-semitism I'm
seeing increased anti-semitism on my
Twitter feed and in my own life but do I
think that that is necessarily
statistically representative no and even
if it is we're gonna need better data
than the ones that are being cited by
the media and all this okay we have time
for a quick Federalist paper here so
every week we go through a federalist
paper were all the way up to Federalist
49 this one's by James Madison in this
one Madison argued specifically with
Thomas Jefferson so Jefferson had
proposed that the new Constitution
allowed that whenever two of the three
branches of government concur a
convention could be called for altering
the Constitution so the judiciary and
the executive don't like what the
legislature is doing so they call for a
new Constitutional Convention Jefferson
was much more of a a Democrat than a
Republican not in the modern sense but
in the idea that you liked direct
popular control a lot more than some of
the other founders he also likes the
idea of constitutional revision on a
fairly consistent basis he argued that
Madison says that if you are continually
revising the Constitution that
undermines its appeal it undermines the
durability of the system he writes a
nation of philosophers is as little to
be expected as the philosophical race of
Kings wished for by Plato in every other
nation the most rational government will
not find it a superfluous advantage to
have the prejudices of the community on
its side the danger of disturbing the
public tranquility by interesting too
strongly the public passions is still a
more serious objection against a
frequent reference of constitutional
questions to the decision of the whole
society so basically for all those
people who claim that Americans in
democracy it's not it's Republic one of
the reasons is because the founders were
deeply fearful of public passions
resulting in bad policy and high rates
of turnover in the consistency of that
policy Madison also argued that the
procedure wouldn't actually curb the
government because the legislature is
more populous than the other two
branches so that means they probably win
any convention fight but once again this
cuts to the heart of how American
government runs it was not designed to
be a system that quote unquote gets
things done it was designed to be a
system replete with gridlock
specifically so that the more unbridled
passions of the public were not the most
easily recognized easily recognized and
put into law by our system the idea is
that if we
really want to get something done we can
but we really better want to get
something done and even then it can't
violate those fundamental rights
enshrined in the Bill of Rights in the
Constitution okay well we will be back
here tomorrow with all the latest i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018